so i just watched the series and i'm
like totally in love with it after
episode seven i was like
is there more am i getting more episodes
but yes
we are renewed
i mean i wanted them immediately like
right then
so i i just have a general question
first when it comes to page to screen
adaptations i think everyone kind of
falls on a spectrum of you know either
being like i want it 100 loyal to the
book or you know just as you know it can
be as much of a remake as it wants to be
where do you fall on that spectrum i
approached it like what do i think are
the most important elements of the story
to keep and what do the fans care the
most about i
am able to
um pull from all the like emails and
letters and comments i've seen
over the years from fans so
that's how i looked at this adaptation
was like what do the original fans care
most about and then also for me like
what it's gonna be most like fun and
exciting to explore because i think um
you know you as a writer have to feel
uh like you're doing something new in a
way too it's not going to be just the
exact same thing but something what's
the new approach and like how
how to make this feel like fresh i love
in the story i mean i love belly's story
of course but i love the story of the
moms being best friends and i love the
idea of like platonic soul mates almost
what was um your inspiration behind
pursuing that story and you know
developing it i think you know when i
first started writing the books um i i
thought a lot about like beaches as a
kid um beaches that movie came out and
it was like i was probably like
really young but kids my age who were
like in elementary school like loved
um that movie and maybe because they
start out as young kids and you see them
over the years but i think there's
something really
lovely and powerful about
friendship between two women
and
for this i really want to preserve
how important that friendship is and how
it's foundational to the whole story
really because these two women create
this
kind of magical place for the kids that
feels really separate from their
everyday lives so that they get to go
and just
be there and um
stop the
everyday work life and i think take a
moment for themselves
as a writer for the novels and also a
writer of novels
uh senior transition kind of going into
tv writing i'm really curious less about
what you
what your what you were taking in from
your novel writing but what you took
from that tv writing what you might what
lessons you might go uh take from from
that experience into
writing you know writing more novels and
especially the idea of like managing a
writer's room like what was that like
well i think that in my novel writing
life
i don't outline
um
and it's very intuitive for me i'm sort
of
picture it like i am
going through a forest
blindfolded in a way and i'm feeling my
way through
and i know
where the finish point is but it's kind
of like how am i getting there
and i also don't write an order and um i
kind of
see it when it's like 85 90 there then
everything
comes into focus for me i often picture
like um iron man you know when it's like
click click click click and all the
pieces are coming together that's how i
see the story and suddenly it becomes
clear to me now tv writing is really
different because you have to outline um
and you have to you know exactly how big
your canvas is
um how many pages you need and with a
book it's really kind of infinite
um
in a book you don't have budget it's a
infinite budget as well it's just you're
only limited by your imagination so uh
what will i learn from this to take with
me i think is
i will be very curious to see for my
next novel if i
try to outline it first um because it's
never worked for me in the past
so we'll see
okay i mean that's amazing i don't like
i feel like i need an outline for
everything because my mind is just like
jumping everywhere so that seems like
a wild process to me but it seems so
successful for me no it's like
definitely it's wild and i think every
time i do it i think uh i never i like
hate my process and i never want to do
it like this again because you are
going through it without knowing what
you're doing and it can be feel very
frustrating
but for me it's part of it
is the exercise of like keeping myself
interested and not
bored where everything can feel like
serendipitous in a way so i think you've
created what i call the asian teen girl
romance extended universe because you
have all of these different stories that
kind of feel like they could exist in
the in the same world but they don't
have to um and i'm very very much
looking forward to xo kitty uh thank you
i'm so excited for that in the distance
um
and i i really like that a lot of your
characters are not just asian but
they're biracial which i think
is a story that we don't hear a lot can
you talk to me about how how it's like
balancing having a story feel authentic
to a character and their and their
personality and who they are but also
not leaning too far into sort of what i
like to call the identity story
um i think you talk a little bit about
that in in the summer i turned pretty
but can you talk a little bit about that
here
i
approach it like you know how can i
write this character authentically and
um
and have it feel real and truthful to
someone's lived experience and i don't
think anyone's lived experience is
wholly encapsulated by their like racial
identity i think um
oftentimes for me as a writer
i'll be asked to do like specifically um
talking about like being an asian
american writer and i uh love to talk
about that at the same time i also um
feel like it's not necessarily the most
interesting thing about me is is that
identity i think that everybody is made
up of a lot of different things
and
as a storyteller first and foremost i'm
thinking about story and
what feels
really true to that story definitely for
sure i mean i really enjoyed that scene
in the series when the mom is talking
about it and her and her
you know her
uh
paramore is are discussing that and it
was a very it felt i could relate to
that a lot so i appreciated that um and
then just as an avid reader myself i
always have you know a genre of book
that i go to to read you know as a
comfort for me it's a regency historical
romance novel do you have a genre or
book that you like to return to as sort
of like this like comfort blanket
something that you like to just enjoy
you know when you have the time
uh for a comfort blanket type of book i
love like
you know your classic uh rom-com type of
book as well um i also like a regency
romance novel um have you ever read
sherry thomas
yes isn't she so good
um
when she makes a return i need her she i
asked her i go please can we get another
one of those because i think everything
she does is great but i miss those and
she doesn't seem like it
so i'll just enjoy what she's done so
far i'll keep asking
for another one
yes okay well i appreciate that we are
all sherry thomas fan she's she's an
amazing writer
and as are you i'm very very excited to
get more of this show and i really want
to thank you for taking the time thank
you so much
thank you
you